[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVE WILLIAMS: A common
challenge for improvement teams
is identifying what changes you can
test to improve a process or problem.
One great method to help you
break down ideas is a tool known
as a "cause-and-effect diagram."
You may have also heard of this tool
referred to as an "Ishikawa diagram"--
attributed to its creator, Kaouru
Ishikawa-- or a "fishbone diagram"
because of the resemblance
to the bones of a fish.
To create a cause-and-effect
diagram, write
the effect in a box on the
right-hand side of the page.
So let's imagine we're working
on improving hand-washing.
All right.
Then draw a horizontal
line across the page.
Decide on a few categories
or causes for the problem.
Useful categories of causes in
the classic fishbone diagram
include people, methods, materials,
equipment, and environment.
Then we can draw a diagonal
line to each of these,
and these are actually the bones
of the fish-- and hence, its name.
The process of categorizing
potential causes
may be very useful to help you
to break down a complex problem
and focus in on it from
various perspectives.
So as you're looking at
each of the categories,
you want to generate a list of causes.
In this example, people
might include clinical staff.
All right.
It also might include
non-clinical staff.
Let's put them as just "other staff."
It might include the methods.
How do you actually wash your hands?
I'll say "wash process."
It could be the materials.
Are you using the right kind of
soap, or does it dry out your hands?
So we'll think about the soap.
It could be the equipment,
like the dispenser.
Is there an easy dispenser to use?
Does it give you the right amount?
Or maybe it's the environment.
Where is the dispenser location?
Is it near the process of care?
Identify the causes by asking why with
people that are closest to the process
until you've reached a
useful level of detail.
That is when the cause is specific
enough to be able to test a change
and to measure its effects.
Sometimes, I like to describe
this for folks that have
children as the five-year-old method.
If you ever had a kid, they
asked you "why" five times
constantly until they get
to the root of the problem.
And you're doing the same thing here.